Brian Skerry: How I wish
everyone saw Bluefin Tuna
the way that I have.
For being underwater with them
I know of their greatness
and I am certain
they possess abilities
and hold secrets
we can barely imagine.
( music )
( applause )
One of my more recent stories
in the magazine;
in March of this year
the magazine published a story
that I photographed about
Bluefin Tuna.
This is a picture that
I made in the Mediterranean
off of Spain where
Bluefin are caught
in giant purse seine nets.
Methods of catching tuna
like this
have been very destructive.
They have actually resulted
in the collapse of tuna stocks
in the Mediterranean and
throughout the Atlantic...
with populations
being decimated.
And this is an image that
I made at the daily tuna auction
at the Tsukiji fish market
in Tokyo.
Every single morning
the tuna bodies
are lined up like cordwood and
auctioned off
to the highest bidder.
It's really the lust for sushi
that has created this.
You know,
I live in New England and
I've been on the water
most of my life.
And I can remember
back in the early 70's,
fishermen catching Bluefin Tuna
and there was no market
for them.
They used to call them
horse-mackerel.
They considered them
trash fish and
would bury them on the beach
if they caught one.
There was really nothing
for them but once that...
that sushi craze sort of
took place and began,
the prices skyrocketed
and all of a sudden
the stocks began to plummet.
But this is what happens,
you know,
every single day. We can't
sustain this kind of thing.
This animal now
has become the most valuable
animal on the planet.
A single Bluefin
has sold for over a
million dollars at this--
these auctions in Tokyo.
So you can imagine with a bounty
like that on their head
the future is probably
not very bright.
There's actually
three species of Bluefin
but we were focusing
on the biggest and,
and sort of most magnificent,
the Atlantic Bluefin Tuna.
It's an animal
that's quite unlike any other.
You know, these are animals
that continue to grow
their entire lives.
If weren't so efficient
at catching them
there would be 30-year old
Bluefin out there
that weigh a ton.
These are animals that are
capable of generating heat
in their body. They are
effectively a warm-blooded fish.
And because of that
they can swim
practically from
the equator to the poles
in search of their prey.
They criss-cross entire oceans
in the course of the year.
There's no predator on land
that covers
that kind of territory.
Um... you know,
they are truly amazing fish.
But to find Bluefin in the wild,
I had to travel to a place
where they are hunted.
And this time it was the Gulf
of St. Lawrence in Canada.
And I would probably rather
not see them caught at all,
but in small ports,
in Nova Scotia and
Prince Edward Island
fishermen head out
during their season
for just a very brief time
and they use only
a rod and a reel
to catch one fish at a time.
The season is very brief.
When I was up there
it only lasted for about a day.
They have extended it now
a little bit longer
but it's still the same quota,
which is very low.
And it's essentially one man,
one fish.
As soon as they are caught
they are processed on the dock,
iced and shipped off to Japan.
And in those weeks before
the fishing season begins
researchers also come here
to tag Bluefin.
They are trying to do science,
trying to look at their
migrations, where they go
and where they
migrate to and from.
And they work with local
fishermen as we see here
who'll catch the fish.
When they hook up on a giant
Bluefin sometimes it takes,
you know, close to
two hours to reel one in
and get it close to the boat.
And they've worked with
a variety of tags
to put on these animals.
But the most effective
or the most productive
over these years
has been satellite tags.
They can tag the animal
and it can stay on for many
months and then it pops off,
sends up a signal where
they can retrieve it
and download the data
and see exactly
where this tuna has migrated to.
And it's been very valuable
as a conservation tool.
And once they
catch the tuna,
after maybe a two-hour fight,
they get it close to the boat
and then they have to
get it up on deck very quickly
and do the science and
work it up.
One of the researchers,
his job is the lip-hooker,
where he uses this big
sort of metal hook
to go through the bottom jaw,
which is the strongest
and then they very quickly
get it up on the boat
and try to do up their...
their science here.
You can see the captain of the
boat is aerating the fish,
he is putting water
inside to aerate the gills,
keep it alive
and they are measuring it,
both length and girth.
They are taking
pictures of the animal,
they are taking a DNA sample,
blood,
all happens usually
in about a minute.
It's amazing how well they work.
So this was a GoPro video that
we did that just shows how
this all happens very quickly.
So they measured as I said,
and you can see the
size of these animals.
It's not the best
with some shadows here,
but you do get a sense
of the massive beast
that this Bluefin is.
So, within,
you know, 60 or 70 seconds
the fish is back into the water
and swimming off with
that tag inside of it.
I also wanted to show
another fishery for Bluefin.
One that happens on the
other side of the Atlantic.
And this is one that
actually dates back
thousands of years.
This is a view of a place
called Barbate, Spain.
A little town in
the Atlantic on the
southern coast of Spain
and it's one of many locations
that has done this very
old method of catching Bluefin
for centuries.
It's a method called the
Almadraba Fishery.
There used to be
many of these places.
Today there is just
a handful left
and Barbate is one of them.
But what they do is
they use a series of nets
to sort of passively
catch the tuna
as they are migrating
from the Atlantic
through the, uh...
Gibraltar Straits into
the Mediterranean
and they get caught in this net.
There's sort of a line
in the ocean there,
those are a line of buoys.
And those are the buoys,
those are the nets,
so it's quite close to shore
that this all happens.
The way it works is the fish
once they hit the tail
of that net
they move through
a series of chambers,
a series of rooms,
different nets and
when they have
enough tuna
in the final chamber,
the "cámara de muerte",
the chamber of death,
they sort of close it off
and then they begin
lifting up the bottom
and they hold
what's known as a "matanza",
the massacre.
And, here we see that
very thing happening.
These fishermen use these
old wooden boats
and they form a square
around that last chamber
and then they slowly begin
muscling up those nets
and the tuna, you know
begin thrashing in very
shallow waters.
We see a Bluefin right up here
swimming right up on
the surface, almost full body
out of the water.
And then once they get
the sort of tuna up there,
they hook them and
bring them on this one boat
where they immediately
bleed them
and begin processing them and...
You know, having swam with
Bluefin underwater
it's always a little difficult
for me to see
this kind of thing.
And I understand
what they are doing
and it's a way of life.
But in some ways
for me it was like
seeing a crime unfold, you know.
I had such reverence
for these animals.
I've always sort of wished
that I could take
these folks underwater,
very few of them dive.
But I always wished
I could take them underwater
to see Bluefin within
its own element
and I have to believe
it would change their mindset.
To be underwater with these
magnificent animals
is to witness
the divine sense of nature.
They are the true
thoroughbreds of the sea
with few if any equals.
With streamline design
that's been
studied by naval engineers,
they swim faster than a torpedo.
And likely posses
physical endurance
that we can hardly fathom.
How I wish everyone
saw Bluefin Tuna
the way that I have.
For being underwater with them
I know of their greatness
and I am certain
they posses abilities
and hold secrets
we can barely imagine.
Thanks very much.
( applause )